there's this um like  Unholy alliance between those who want  to control the resources make money and  all of that build their bureaucracies  all that power stuff that we know about  and these globalist environmentalists  the green religion and they've like  locked arms in basically coming and  trying to control and drive mankind off  off the land that's oh that's very uh  telling and I think that correlates with  what you're saying about going after the  standards for the tortoise yeah that's  that's why so you've got you know this  the global environmentalists that are  like saying we got to save the tortoise  which it's all based upon lies and then  you have the those who want to control  the the resources the the subsurface  mineral rights and the land and so forth  saying like well come come with us and  we'll  will stop people from using this and  then then they take it for themselves  and that's that's what's been happening  all over the West